the goal of this video is to find out
how much mud is actually needed to hide
from Predator so at a certain
point we will find out how much mud that
is if I can't do that then this whole
thing has been a
waste dude what the
heck Nico yeah you seen predator of
course well how do they defeat Predator
well harnold sger covers himself in mud
so the Predator is ther can't see them
and then he gets them exactly and it
works perfectly Predator with his
thermal vision can't defeat Arnold
because Arnold is covered in mud which
is would totally not work in real life
by the way because the moment you put
mud on your skin your Skin's going to
war the mud you'd still just look the
same on a thermal now this is the test
this is theot we cut to what predator
sees right oh he's got like water with
dirt in it on them and he'd be heating
it up this whole time cuz he's
constantly flexing his muscles do you
remember that short film where Clint
made Sam put like a lot of Clay on his
head yes I feel like you're going to
need to do that much mud clay whatever
Well here here's what I'm thinking I've
got a stock pond on my property in Texas
I know a couple buddies out there who
have thermal imaging devices we could go
to my stock pond and we could try this
for real the thermal image has to scan
across and not see you yeah do I think
it's possible yes do I think with going
to require more mud than Arnold has
shown in this scene yes you better hope
they don't call Sergeant Sizzle Wizzle
not Sergeant Sizzle
whistle oh and Nick I got news for you
too what's up you're going to have to
come out to Texas to film this with me
[Music]
okay other than that it'll probably be
like this all day Nick we got perfect
mud weather couldn't imagine it being
better I mean it's been spitting rain
the last 3 days I mean you can't get
better mud than this how's the mud
situation
Jake I thought there'd be more water
than
this
hi I mean that's mud that's mud for sure
I mean look at that that's that's going
to slop that's going to slop up
definitely more dry than I'd like it to
be we're going to need water boys all we
got to do from here is run the hose get
a little bit more water in here oh there
he is there's dale dale bacon what's up
Dale
what's up
nice he'll fall in like a dog that's
awesome this is that good mud look at
that oh
yeah yeah I know good mud when I see it
boys oh yeah that's going to do perfect
Predator mud that's like the same
consistency color texture as the movie
yep today's the big day um we've got our
Mangrove set up we've got industry
experts we had to call in some of the
best of the best and right here we have
Brandon Herrera yeah the best of the
best didn't show up so uh that came out
now what do you have here Brandon so we
got a couple different thermal devices
uh this right here is a pulsar thermal
hunting binoculars and then we've got
this right here is a Trijicon reap IR uh
this is in a couple video games and such
but this is a thermal scope for for
hunting and today it's going to be for
hunting you you think you'll really be
able to find me with that cuz I'm pretty
stealthy I can see you perfectly he's
going to need a lot of mud what I think
is going to happen though the longer the
mud is on him the more his body heat is
going to heat the mud up so I think he's
going to need fresh mud like each time I
get covered you and crispy are over
there and you have to scan and see if
you can see me and then obviously it's
not going to work right and so then
eventually I'm just going to sit here
and the guys are going to shovel mud on
me I have a snorkel for safety safety
first right who wants to help I wanted
to help on multiple levels even just
mentally you keep saying Predator it's a
victim mentality he's a yucha so let's
remember he's just another species out
there oh you're going to Google on me a
super nerd look at man like it doesn't
hurt to be uh you know well informed you
know so I just I would love to cover you
in mud he's not even a predator
you Harley I need I need help yeah we
need help bro we need a mud buddy let's
get on the inside got hey you all know
I'm straight move it I'm making a badass
video here man rubbing a a man down with
all this I feel like I'm at Burning Man
again in the orgy Dome you don't want
that that Predator triple beam to head
shot you cuz your Earl you know right
yeah all
[Music]
right I Contin need you to spray my back
go all right guys look I'm de I'm Dem
mudding right now and I'm hosing myself
off I'm not going to tell you how this
went if you want to find that out you
got to watch till the end but right now
I'm going to take some time to tell you
about today's sponsor raycon while
Harley hoses me down if you guys don't
know raycons are the best of the best
okay they have the perfect inear fit and
they're going to last you all day no
matter what you're doing whether you're
covered in mud whether you're out at the
job whether you're out at the gym
personally I use raycons anytime that
I'm not hiding from predator in the mud
and the best part about raycons is that
they come up about half the price as
other premium wireless earbuds on the
market how about the bass I like
headphones with good bass do they have
that oh dude rayons have the best base
more
base not just regular base premium base
that means boom you're going to be
bumping all day long look you may be
familiar with raycon because they made a
name for themselves in premium audio but
now for this holiday season they're
going above and beyond with new lines
like raycon home and raycon power Tech
prod products like the magic 180
charging cable and the faucet filter
they are providing premium Tech products
at a great price their products have
earned tens of thousands of fstar
reviews online so if you go to bon.com
Corridor crew they are having a huge
sale an early Black Friday sale where
everything in the site is 20 to up to
50% off 25% off Fitness earbuds 30% off
Tech kits 30 % off impact earbuds and
impact speaker and 50% off other select
items I mean you can't miss with raycon
donut I need some more raycon talking
points raycons come on what do you got
for note not his code that's all you got
to do is click the link in the
description below or go to by
raycon.com Corr roll it rolling and
action
[Music]
all right jig Moment of Truth you're
getting
hunted so Predator Vision as far as like
the actual color heat on this he's
actually pretty good I don't think I
would have stopped the black heat you
can see him a bit his eyes and mouth are
glowing he looks like the I like totals
kid close your eyes this is crazy I
think all of us went in thinking I'll be
janky but we'll be able to tell really
quickly what's going on when he lays
back in those
sticks dude what the
heck
[Music]
does it work yeah bro
it's it's what the like you have all
these military dudes and we're like what
the
holy that's all I'm going to say Finn
can you walk closer to Jake really
quick that is ridiculous like if you're
just doing quick scan wow yeah yeah
I so I see him I'm probably cuz I'm
aware of where he is however like a
couple more branches and he's gone uh I
was expecting these to work pretty well
they're several thousand dollars you
know when we were to the left where the
brush was covering him slightly we could
not see him at all they're not pierced
in the mud very well man I thought this
was total the comparison of him
earlier versus him covered mud now this
at a long enough
distance might work Jake how you feeling
man I I I don't know I can't I can't
really hear cuz I have these ear plugs
in and is it working yeah yes like that
camera I can see you I would not second
guess if I'm just panning across are you
telling me that only this much mud is
good enough to hide from Predator dude I
seriously thought we were going to have
to shovel mud on you if we were
somewhere like let's say we didn't know
where you were at and our job was to
find you I dude no let's do exactly that
I will hide somewhere use foliage too
and your your job will be to find me
legit find so this is going to be like a
a $155,000 game of hideand-seek
basically yeah I think this video became
hot wait so hold on you get to do the
can I do the thing you can do
it apparently all you need is some mud
so now we're going to play the real
game is white skin Oh My godak out of
here weakness this is why we need you
dude this is my boy here you think I
want him hunted by a yaa no shot humans
number one bro humans number one
starting to
rain best place man's number one bro
number one all right Predators Jake is
out there somewhere all
right head out this way and we'll start
searching for our boy Jake's like a try
hard sneaky so you know he's not going
to make it easy he could be up even he
could be in the tree up he would
wouldn't he well first off can anyone
see him from here on The Thermals I
can't see him from here I can't see I
see a couple areas that are a little
dark but I don't know oh even with the
naked eye I can't see him I'm not
catching anything think I I saw
something on thermal it's kind of about
that way yeah do you guys see that like
directly to my 12 here where I'm
pointing that's my dog wait past the dog
oh like kind of like laying down yeah
that looks oddly person shaped we'll go
over here and then we'll do a a canvas
of this area right here and we'll scan
again I swear there's got to be
something
like yeah that's the embarrassing thing
if he's behind us now that's that's what
that would be the mess up I have seen
nothing can I see that real quick can't
see
him
nothing I I'm not picking other than us
I'm not picking anything
up not picking up over
here you f yeah what the it's
crazy right now like we're right on top
of this mofo we are literally 25 ft from
him and no one can see because
they're looking under thermals which
Predator would have been doing he is
literally Blended in like this is bright
daylight and he is evading us
if this is evening and it's a little
cool or anything or he's just sticks
next to that completely done what the
heck
colder we were right there
colder oh
yeah come
here come here good
boy man best friend man's best friend I
think I see some legs here I think I see
some legs
an oddly Watson shaped
person dude we were all looking right
here and everyone missed I would have
never found that you got busted by the
dog the dog did it four thermos and no
one seen
him dude I did not expect this to work
nearly this good four sets of thermals
verse one good boy this was way beyond
our expectations and now we know that
the Predator move movie isn't that far
off the only thing left to do from here
subscribe we go back to LA Joe ni the
results and I think he's going to be
shocked to be honest Hey Jake all right
things happened out there uh I can't
wait for you to see
this well look at you C the image
quality is better than in Predator with
you crawling through the mud Jake I
think you got it in you to be an action
star there you go I'm Coming For You
Arnold here it
is
oh really is this real that's re that's
raw wow yeah that's cool that's crazy it
actually worked incredibly well yeah you
can't see you can't tell at all can't
see anything you actually blend is are
you wearing as much mud as we see in the
video there yes really that's it just
that like the like that's that's it that
was all the mud that I had on a finger
paint level of mud actually worked out
of all the things we've done out of all
the experiments we've tried I would
argue that this one worked the best I
did not think this was going to work at
all I'll be honest I didn't think it was
going to either after this experience I
would call it a legitimate tactical play
to try to camouflage yourself from
thermals you know Jake I appreciate you
going through the effort of getting
dirty to figure out if these movie
tropes are actually real and would
actually work thanks for not believing
in me once again Nico so hopefully
there's more of these that we can do uh
if people have ideas let us know in the
comments we'll be scann all right Jake
I'll see you
later